the kungfu kid that's right kung fu
because my videos are accurate and he
did not learn karate there's even a
scene in the movie where Jaden Smith's
mom calls it karate and he's like it's
not karate Mon
I guess the producers didn't read that
part of the script okay so if you've
seen the old Karate Kid you know the
entire formula of this movie and I'm not
even joking around at all kid and mom
move kid gets a crush on a girl kid gets
his ass kicked by wannabe boyfriend
maintenance man takes the kid under his
wing and teaches him martial arts the
kid trains to face off against the
douchebags at the end of the movie for
respect literally the same formula yes I
felt if it ain't broke don't fix it
there are parts in this movie where
situations and dialogue were ported
straight from the old movie to this one
like kind of to a lazy degree which I
found kind of lame I mean come up is
your own dialogue [ __ ] but [ __ ] making a
karate kid' remake and calling it
something else didn't quite work out for
never back down so maybe I understand
although they get no points for
originality and as much as I wanted to
rush the [ __ ] out of this movie there
was some good to it and bad and it goes
so some people who screamed this movie
at show as said that Jaden Smith was a
really good actor truth is he's really
not I mean he's okay in some scenes but
he's horrible in others although he's a
good martial artist I'll give him that
I mean if you're looking for Dakota
Fanning and dreads you're not gonna find
it in this one and they're like 11 years
old in this movie I mean girl problems
at 11 seriously I mean 16 maybe but 11 I
was 11 once I think I just watched
cartoons I'm a flip side you can't
really help but laugh when these kids
are getting their asses kicked I mean in
the tournament they're getting kicked in
the face and flying out of the ring I
left a bastard and the movie was two and
a half hours long seriously I mean -
yeah maybe but as long as Robin Hood is
that necessary I mean this is the only
movie where I hope the director's cut is
a half an hour shorter on the plus side
the fighting in this movie some really
solid kungfu by the end of the movie
Jaden Smith who plays a kid named Ray
has pre PhD it's an absolute badass so I
mean props to him Jackie Chan teaches
him some legit kung fu' me none of this
bluffing a deck and painting house and
then voila you're a black belt
admit it as much as this classic you're
still gonna get your ass handed to you
if you paint a fence because that would
make every carpenter like a ninja master
what Jesus Christ was a ninja master he
would not have stood for it he would
have beaten some Roman ass okay I'm
ranting porn is painters and fighters
they're different
I mean Jaden Smith was all like blocking
tennis balls running on the Great Wall
chyna he was training hardcore and it
showed and you kind of felt it like by
the end of the movie in the tournament
you really want him to win and you kind
of feel like even if he doesn't win he
showed up and he earned some respect and
that's good enough although it's totally
not beat that kids asthma win so as much
as I wanted to roast this movie because
of my nostalgia I can't totally do that
what sucked were the dialogue in
situations that were pulled straight
from the last movie with no originality
the longhouse runtime coeliac karate
when it's clearly kungfu and james smith
acting at times i guess he got his
mommy's genes but it does have some
hardcore advanced martial arts compared
to the classic movie and it's really
cool to see dre train and become really
badass over time and to people who
insist this movie will not hold the
candle to the original that nostalgic
part of me wants to say you're probably
right but it's a rated PG movie starring
an eleven-year-old safe to say it's not
meant for people who grew up with the
original Karate Kid if you're an adult
who's bitching about the new Karate Kid
movie it's like being an adult bitching
about a new Power Rangers movie it's
just probably not meant for you for a
new generation if they don't get
fidgeting a two-and-a-half-hour movie
and people can want to see
eleven-year-old to get kicked in the
face just saying however I will say that
I'd watched this movie again before I
watch the a-team again so I mean that's
something so when a weekend verse all
80s movies remakes that's the take on it
comment below let me know what you think
and click here to see more
[Music]